let's get more now on the fbi raid on
mar-a-lago which the former president
has dismissed as an attack by radical
left democrats the justice department is
investigating the discovery of
classified papers that were taken
to mr trump's florida estate after his
presidency ended instead of being
transferred to the national archive as
required by law in the last few minutes
the court has ruled that the powerful
ways and means committee of politicians
in washington has been granted
permission to view
the former president's tax records
well we can speak now to jason miller
who was the chief advisor or very senior
adviser certainly for the donald trump
2016 presidential campaign
remained
a remainder adviser to pretty recently
to be honest it's good to have you here
with us uh on this story and for the fbi
to move in like this
they must have some pretty good
information what were these
documents what what do the documents
relate to do you think well this is a
pretty egregious example of
politicization when it comes to the law
enforcement and criminal justice system
in the united states so after a
presidency there are certain documents
that are handed back over to national
archives those are filed away and stored
usually those are kept for 12 years then
many times they're made public depending
on what they were there was a concern
that there were a number of boxes that
were kept at mar-a-lago that were
mistakenly transferred to the
president's residence after he left the
white house those had been returned the
president's team has been working with
the doj on any follow-ups that they had
saying that they're willing to uh help
them out as far are there any follow-up
questions things of that so the fact
that the fbi came in in a very
politicized rage and did this can only
be done for one reason and that's to try
to hurt president trump on politics the
undermining
that we're seeing here of our entire
constitution is pretty egregious but
hang on the prosecutors
um think there's something going on here
the fbi clearly think there's something
going on here and the fbi have been able
to persuade a judge
that it's possible that a crime has been
committed here well and that's a sad
reality about the american justice
system is you can always find one judge
who's going to agree with whether it be
rogue agents or politicized department
of justice that's just the sad reality
fact of the matter is president trump
has not been accused and has not been
charged with doing anything wrong and so
again going back to the point that his
legal team had been working with the doj
and said if there were an open book if
there's any follow-up that you need any
other aspect that you're trying to get
to the bottom of we'll work with you on
it so to go in to send in these agents
uh to go and crack open his safe i mean
this this is a former president of the
united states you expect to see this in
venezuela cuba you don't expect to see
at the united states so are you honestly
saying this is a political conspiracy
oh i don't think it's because because if
it's a political conspiracy it involves
prosecutors it involves the fbi the head
of which was appointed by donald trump
it involves most likely his own attorney
general it involves a judge as i was
just saying well i mean it beggars
belief it's not a conspiracy mark it's
not a conspiracy when it's out in the
open i do think that there's a political
element in the doj and keep in mind what
president trump has had to deal with
from the fbi ever since he first ran for
office whether it be jim comey whether
it be page and strzok of course the fbi
officials that were texting back and
forth with each other president trump
has uh made them a little bit famous uh
but we've seen the impeachment one
impeachment two the russia witch hunt
this is just the last documents why did
he take 15 boxes of documents to
mar-a-lago in the first place so couple
things on that i don't have first-hand
knowledge about say for example what was
in the documents one of the things to
keep in mind they were classified
because the department of justice got
them back well subsequently said they
contained classified documents well keep
in mind that there are different levels
of classification anyone can go through
anyone in the intel community and just
mark ts or top secret on something even
if it's innocuous if there's nothing
that's actually sensitive to it if it
has sci after the ts then that means
that some something actually sensitive
what we don't know is actually what was
there could have been transferred by
mistake could have been something the
president thought he had already
declassified that's important to keep in
mind as well but he has previous on this
if you believe maggie haberman of the
new york times he
has on two or three occasions tried to
flush documents
down the toilets at the white house and
she has is producing a book and claims
to have photographs i saw the picture of
documents
with donald trump's hand why does he
want to get rid of documents like this
why does he want to stash away documents
at mar-a-lago well keep let's go and
separate them out because what we don't
know is what those documents or those
pictures allegedly were with the lou for
example so i've seen the president i've
been with him when he gets done reading
an article and he rips in half to uh
remind himself that he's done reading it
he'll toss it to the side and so there's
not really a deeper thought that's been
put into it we don't know what we're
actually in those boxes and again it
could have been very innocuous they
could have been anything from notes from
a foreign leader uh to some memento uh
but the fact is unless the fbi comes
back or the doj comes back and says
there is ts
sci
which is the secure compartmented
information unless they come back and
say that which i think is pretty notable
they haven't then i think this is pretty
ridiculous but it's all catching up with
him isn't it if you
now have is he's got to
give up his tax records to the ways and
means committee this house of
representatives committee he's been
resisting that i don't know why has he
been resisting that well because
ultimately the democrats that are
running the committee are just going to
go through and try to make his life
miserable to attack him mark do you
think that it's just a coincidence that
all this is happening is president trump
is winning straw polls showing that he
has a firm grip on the republican party
and there is other polling out there
showing that he would beat joe biden in
a head-to-head in a rematch look i think
president trump is going to run again in
2024. he will i think he will i've
canceled him that he should have
announced already
i think the quicker he goes and does it
i think the better so all of this
happening this isn't by accident the
january 6 hearings that are going on
well this is the issue that is the big
issue isn't it
pretty damning evidence in those
hearings and there are now calls for a
criminal investigation well with regard
to the hearings of course there were
things that he was criticized on
politically uh as far as how quickly he
acted and things of that nature but
again he has not been charged with
anything they have not referred anything
for him but
it's what he knew at the time and you've
got this evidence from cassidy hutcheson
for instance for instance it was an aide
let me just put the i mean she said that
he knew the crowd had weapons but he
didn't care they're not here to hurt me
take away the security screening
machines he said so president trump has
said that's not true and with regard to
cassidy hutchinson her entire story
hold on hold on but she's very young
she's very impressionable and also too
when you're talking about someone's
memory that can get a little bit bumpy
so for example
she repeated a secondhand story that
president trump supposedly leaped from
the backseat of the beast on that day
the presidential limo he wasn't even in
the presidential limo so people hear
things second hand they go and repeat it
and again she's young she's an
impressionable because there are also
text messages of her laughing about the
january 6 committee
when they were chanting pence but that
wasn't president trump but that was
since trump apparently said according to
some of the evidence of the the maiden
assad saying it's good for too good for
him and stuff like this i mean
so i was not i spoke with the president
that morning on january 6 and i spoke
with him in the evening and i know
president trump he would not have
cheered on people saying something like
that about his vice president they may
have disagreed he may have thought that
they would have
vice president pence should have acted
differently but he would never go and
encourage lawlessness here's the point
you say he's going to run again
when did you last speak to him do you
know that he's going to run again uh i
if i was a gambling person i would bet
that he is going to run uh i spoke to
them last week we had dinner two weeks
ago i'm not going to call him from the
uk because seeing what the fbi and doj
are doing i'm sure they'd be tapping my
phone so i'm not going to call them
international here's the point can you
really have a president who is accused
of fomenting an insurrection and who
still does not accept
that he lost
the election in 2020 can you really have
a president like that running again for
office absolutely because we have the
greatest economy in american history we
did not have inflation there were no new
wars that the u.s had entered into now
you look at what's happening with
ukraine with china
always democracy this is not about
ukraine it's not about
you know the economy or unemployment
this is about the very fundamental
uh base of american democracy and he is
saying i did not lose an election and he
is insisting now still at rallies i did
not lose an election when quite patently
is there any evidence
that you have seen
that he
that that election was unfair so i think
i i think that the election was legally
rigged in the way that they changed
legally rigged they changed the rules
the voting rules in the middle of the
game well for both sides i mean this no
i'm talking about an actual rigging of
an election
republicans were saying this third world
country it's third world rigging so so i
did where is the the no
hold on
so there were a lot of examples of fraud
and irregularities on election day i did
not see enough on election day that
would have tilted the election i've been
very clear about both when i talked to
the committee so biden won the election
uh biden did win the election biden did
win the election biden did when they
left okay did you tell
president trump as his senior adviser
that biden has won this election so i
had a number of conversations with the
president we talked through as the data
was coming did you tell him that biden
has won this election give it up hold on
because president trump had a number
hold on he had a number of legal
challenges to go and take on the issue
and the fact that they had legally
rigged it that was available to him to
go and exhaust all of those which i said
you should because they did go and
change the rules in an unconstitutional
manner in the middle of the game and so
ultimately at the end uh when i had the
conversation with president trump on
january 6 and said we've got to get this
statement out say we're going to have an
orderly transition the other guy's
coming in in two weeks but he's still
not accepting it he's still not
accepting it how can you
still support
a man
on which
who you have a fundamental disagreement
with over whether an election was won or
not i mean he's not small stuff is it to
be fair you you think biden won that
election
donald trump is convinced he didn't so
presumably you can't support him during
another election campaign no of course
i'll be i'll be i'll be there to help
president trump because i believe that
he's a strong leader for the united
states i think that what he did on
taking on the establishment taking on
the swamp whether it be the better trade
policies better tax policies actually
standing up and coming up with better
solutions against these uh
and more republicans might
have i think better things to say about
important things though i think a lot of
folks particularly with the audience
here in the uk might not realize that
our u.s constitution lays out the all
election law changes
for the sake of having presidential
elections need to be made by state
legislatures there were a number of
states democratically controlled states
that went and circumvented that they had
executives whether it be county
executives or mayors that changed the
system and they blind sent out okay
hundreds of thousands or millions of
rigged election no i mean you accept
that because you think back but can i
just
the new york post supported donald trump
it now doesn't support him it said
recently he is unworthy to be this
country's chief executive again do you
not
agree that the man you say you're going
to support in the if he if he runs you
say he will run
um do you not
agree with them that he's unworthy to
run again completely disagree he didn't
have the newspapers or the endorsements
or the elected officials behind him in
2016 when he first ran and he's never
had the strong backing of the
establishment
look i think ultimately he has a strong
connection with his base people know
that he's fighting for them and as we
look around the world with everything
that's happening today i think a lot
more people say you know what that's
fine if we have a couple of mean tweets
maybe people might disagree on a couple
things on the personality at least he's
a real leader a lot better what we have
right now in the white house okay and
you'll be working with him um joining
his campaign team a running getter
fastest growing social media company in
history so i don't know if i'll step
away from that but i'll be there helping
him so you're supporting him and you've
got to plug in